The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
-- dissolved in water,
such that there are six water
molecules arranged around the
metal in an octahedral array.
You will see here that I have
colored one of the water
molecule's oxygens in this peach
color because we are going to
talk about reactions today.
In fact, I am going to
introduce you to the idea of a
potential energy surface for a
reaction.
I am taking water substitution
as an example and as a context
for this, but this very general.
And the same ideas that we are
going to be talking about today
would apply to reactions in
organic chemistry or in
biochemistry.
Let's imagine having this
system dissolved in liquid
water.
And let's further imagine that
we have some way,
perhaps, for isotopic labeling
of the oxygens in the water to
differentiate from those that
start out on the metal complex.
And so I am differentiating
here by using a green color for
the oxygen in a liquid water
solvent.
And in this reaction,
it is a very simple reaction in
which liquid water from
solution, --
-- we are going to talk about
reaction mechanisms today,
somehow will come in and bind
to the metal center and displace
one water molecule from the
metal center.
And I will represent that here
by saying that we would lose
that one water molecule that
I've colored this way.
And that gives us our product,
which is very similar to the
starting material in this case,
--
-- except that one water
molecule, the one here colored
green, has replaced one of the
others.
And when we look at this type
of reaction as a function of
which 3d transition element we
have at the center of the
octahedron, we find that the
time constant for this reaction
taking place varies quite
dramatically.
And this is informative with
respect both to the mechanism of
the reaction,
as we will discuss,
and to the electronic structure
attributes of the systems that
control the way a metal binds to
its ligands.
And so, for example,
let's make a little table of
the metal n plus.
And we will take the log of the
rate constant for the reaction,
which I will denote with this
k.
Small k is going to be our rate
constant.
And the units that we would
find for such a rate constant
would be reciprocal seconds to
describe how fast this takes
place.
And, if we start down here at
chromium three plus,
we would find that the log of
the rate constant is
approximately minus 6.
And then, if we went to
vanadium two plus,
the rate constant log goes to
minus 2.
So the reaction is faster than
it is for chromium three.
And then, if we look at some of
the other d ions that are
possible here,
we could have chromium two plus
or copper two plus.
And, for both of those,
the log of the rate constant is
9.
You can see,
because I am taking the log of
these first order rate
constants, the actual rates of
these processes differ here by
15 orders of magnitude.
That is an enormous difference.
So it is not true that whatever
metal ion you have at the
center, the rate at which water
comes on and off and it
exchanges with water from
solution is about the same.
It is not.
It differs over an enormous
range of actual rates,
many orders of magnitude,
depending on exactly which
metal ion you have here.
And so I will classify these as
either slow or fast.
And we will say that here,
we are slow.
And here we are fast.
And, of course,
there are cases that are
somewhat in between.
But I will be giving you a
little bit of nomenclature that
arises from the study of such
ligand substitution rates in a
little while.
Here is one type of
substitution reaction.
Now, I would like you to
consider a different type of
substitution reaction,
one that does not have a
product that is essentially
identical to the starting
material.
And that will be one as shown
here.
Let's use the metal tungsten at
the bottom of Group 6,
a 5d transition element.
This makes a very stable binary
compound with carbon monoxide in
which six carbon monoxide
ligands bind to the metal center
at the corners of an octahedron.
And in this tungsten
hexacarbonyl system,
you are going to find that,
as you will be seeing in
recitation this week,
these CO ligands are pi-acids,
they are very high in the
spectrochemical series.
This leads to a molecule like
this being colorless.
It has a large delta O.
And because ligands are
pi-acidic and the metal center,
as you will see,
this metal center is a d six
pi-base,
the metal itself is very
electronically complimentary to
its set of six carbon monoxide
ligands.
So a system like this is very
stable.
And what you might like to do
is to tag some biomolecule with
a tungsten pentacarbonyl
fragment, so that you could use
the vibrational spectroscopy
associated with these CO
oscillators to watch some
biological process that has that
thing attached to it.
And one example of a
substitution reaction you might
wish to use would be the one
shown here.
This ligand that I am currently
sketching is one in which we
have a phosphorus with a lone
pair and three phenyl groups
attached to it.
A phenyl group is a benzene
ring where one of the positions
is substituted.
This ligand here,
then, is triphenylphosphine,
and this is a good ligand for
various types of metals.
And, in fact,
one of the Nobel laureates that
I may have mentioned in passing
this semester,
Sir Jeffrey Wilkinson,
used triphenylphosphine as a
ligand in the preparation of
what is now universally known as
Wilkinson's hydrogenation
catalyst.
So this ligand is quite common,
indeed, and well-known.
And what we might like to do is
to replace one carbon monoxide
with this triphenylphosphine
ligand.
That would be a simple
substitution reaction.
We would like one equivalent of
carbon monoxide to be evolved as
CO gas in this reaction.
But we find that we can put
tungsten hexacarbonyl in the
presence of triphenylphosphine,
and nothing really happens.
They just sit there and look at
each other.
They do not react.
So one of the things that
happens when you are learning to
do synthetic chemistry is that
the outcome of a reaction can be
either that it proceeded cleanly
onto products.
And one possible outcome is
there was no reaction at all.
And so this is what we will
call no thermal reaction.
And that means that just with
the energy supplied by the
temperature of the room,
the reaction is not proceeding
in the forward direction.
And what that may mean is that
there is an energy barrier to
this reaction.
And energy barriers are going
to be a topic of this lecture in
a few moments,
but there may be an energy
barrier.
And we don't have sufficient
energy to surmount the barrier,
so the substitution reaction is
not taking place.
But we find that if we shine
light on the system,
UV light, then the reaction
takes place.
And we form this desired
product that has one of the
carbon monoxide ligands replaced
with triphenylphosphine.
That would be the initial
product formed in such a
process.
Still octahedral,
now five CO ligands instead of
six, and one of them replaced by
triphenylphosphine.
And it occurs under the action
of UV light.
If you put a photon into the
system for some reason,
we can now surmount the energy
barrier to the reaction,
blow one of the CO molecules
away as CO gas.
We might, in fact,
in practice,
possibly be bubbling an inert
gas like N two through
the solution to sweep the
evolved carbon monoxide out of
the system to help the reaction
go to completion as we are
carrying out such a prep.
But, in any event,
the key feature is that it goes
under photolysis in the presence
of a UV lamp but not simply
through input of normal thermal
energy.
And, in thinking back to the
development of the electronic
structure of systems of this
type, we can actually begin to
understand this.
Because we have an energy
diagram, a d orbital splitting
diagram for simplicity,
where we have our t(2g) set and
our e(g)*.
And tungsten is in Group 6,
the ligands are all neutral,
so this is d six.
This is a common electron count
for octahedral systems that are
quite stable.
And CO is high in the
spectrochemical series,
so it leads to a large value of
delta O.
This splitting here between
t(2g) and e(g) is large.
And that means we have an s
equals zero state,
with the system not being
paramagnetic,
all the electrons paired up in
t(2g) and this big gap.
And what happens when we add a
photon to the system,
we can promote the system into
an excited state.
And, in order to satisfy the
spin selection rule,
this excited state will have no
net spin polarization.
This one is s equals zero,
this one is s equals zero to
satisfy the spin selection rule
that we have talked about.
But notice, now,
in the excited state --
-- we have an electron in e g
star.
And, as I was discussing last
time, when you look at the MO
theory for a problem like this,
e(g)* is sigma antibonding with
respect to the ligands.
I am going to illuminate that
for you very clearly in a few
moments with a graphic,
but this is sigma star with
respect to the ligands.
So what are we doing?
We are taking an electron,
here, that is pi bonding
because CO is a pi-acid ligand.
In the ground state,
this electron that we are going
to promote is helping to bind
the carbon monoxide ligands to
the metal.
And then, when we input that
photon and we produce an excited
state, that same electron now
has been taken away from our sum
total of bonding.
And it has been added to an
antibonding orbital.
And the effect of that is to
"labialize" one of the carbon
monoxide ligands,
allowing it to dissociate from
the metal center producing an
unsaturated intermediate that
can be captured by the lone pair
of triphenylphosphine.
That word I just used,
labialized, we have from Henry
Taube.
Henry Taube,
Nobel Prize in 1983.
If you want to read more about
Henry Taube and his
contributions to chemistry and,
in fact, the study of ligand
substitution reactions and the
relationship of reaction rates
to the population of the e g
star orbitals,
then I would direct you to the
1983 section of the Nobel Prize
dot org website.
And you can read his biography,
his Nobel Prize lecture and his
banquet address.
These are all things that
Professor Schrock from our
department is doing this week in
Sweden, so shortly,
you will be able to read his
contributions to that website.
And I am sure you will all find
that to be pretty exciting,
as I do.
But Henry Taube,
this Nobel Prize winner,
coined the terms "inert" and
"labile."
These terms,
inert and labile,
they refer to rates of ligand
substitution reactions.
If a complex is to be thought
of as inert, it isn't really
inert.
What that means is that its
substitution reactions are slow.
And, on the other hand,
if a system is to be referred
to labile, that means that its
ligand substitution reactions
are fast.
And over there on the left,
we looked at a set of four
metal ions whose aqua-complexes
could be classified as either
inert or as labile.
So let me relate that to the
occupation of the eg star
energy level.
Here what we have,
t(2g) and e(g)*.
In the case of chromium three
plus or vanadium two
plus,
since vanadium is in Group 5
and chromium is in Group 6,
both of these metal ions have a
d three electron
configuration.
And so, when we populate our
d-orbital splitting diagram for
these two systems,
here is the result.
We have an s equals
three-halves ground state,
three unpaired electrons.
The system is paramagnetic.
You could certainly calculate
the spin-only magnetic moment
for such a system.
And e(g)* is not occupied.
We have three electrons,
here, in t(2g).
t(2g) is basically nonbonding
if the ligand is neither a
pi-base nor a pi-acid.
This is three nonbonding
electrons centered in d(xz),
d(yz), and d(xy),
which is t(2g) on our metal ion
chromium three plus
in the hexa-aquo system or
vanadium two plus in
the hexa-aquo system.
And these are inert and slow.
And then, we have two more
cases to discuss.
And, again, here is our t(2g)
and our e(g)*.
Notice that if we go from
chromium three plus
to chromium two plus,
we go up 15 orders
of magnitude in ligand
substitution rate just by
changing the charge by one unit.
And what is going on here?
Well, now chromium two
is d four,
and the four electrons go in
and populate like this.
So eg* now has an electron in
it.
And that makes it related to
the excited state here of
tungsten hexacarbonyl because
both of those,
if you were to write out their
electronic configuration,
would have eg*1 as the
population of eg*.
In the case of copper two plus,
we have a situation
similar to chromium two plus
in that the complex
is labile.
It is undergoing substitution
associated with a rate constant
here whose log is 9.
This is undergoing exchange of
water molecules from liquid
solution onto the metal very
rapidly.
And this is a d nine
case.
The electrons go in like this.
And this is an s equals
one-half system with a single
unpaired electron.
Both of these are paramagnetic.
Both of these have a population
of e g star.
And the two ions that have
e(g)* that contain electrons
have fast ligand exchange rates.
When e(g)* is not occupied,
the ligand substitution rates
are very slow.
And we can understand that
because of the antibonding
character of e(g)*.
There is an additional nuance,
which is when e(g)* is occupied
by an odd number of electrons,
we can get what is called a
Jahn-Teller distortion.
And that distortion is a
structural response to the odd
electronic population of e(g)*.
It is a distortion of the
molecule that makes these
systems, the chromium two
and copper two
the fastest of all
the 3d metal ions for exchanging
water molecules.
Let's look at a structure of
one of these systems briefly.
Here is the result of a quantum
chemical calculation optimizing
the structure of chromium two
hexaaquo two plus.
This system as a spin
polarization of four,
meaning we do have the four
unpaired electrons,
three of which are in t(2g) and
one of which is in e(g)*.
This is how the molecule
optimizes without using any
symmetry constraints based on
the density functional theory
model that is typically in use
these days for optimizing
geometries of molecules.
And what you can see is that
this program I am using to
display the structure is drawing
four of the lines from the
chromium ion to the oxygens.
And the other two it is not
drawing.
And the reason for that,
if I go ahead and use the tools
in this program to find out just
what are those chromium oxygen
distances in this hexaaquo ion,
what we find out is that four
of them, the four where it is
choosing to draw the lines
between the metal and the
oxygen, are about 2.1 angstroms.
Whereas, to the two oxygens
where it is not drawing the
metal oxygen line,
the distance is about 2.45
angstroms.
This molecule,
this hexaaquo ion,
has decided to deviate from a
pure octahedral geometry because
what it has done is it has
stretched two of the oxygens
along an axis and made those two
water molecules move farther
away from the metal center.
And that has to do with the
Jahn-Teller distortion that I
mentioned a moment ago,
when e(g)* is occupied by an
odd number of electrons.
Now, if you see that two waters
have moved far away from the
metal and four are in closer as
a result of how e(g)* is
populated, then which d orbital
do you think has the e(g)*
electron?
d z squared*,
that is right.
And that means the two
molecules that can interact with
the two big lobes of d z squared
along the axis,
those are repelled away from
the metal more than the other
four that are in the x,y-plane
because we don't have any
electron in x squared minus y
squared,
that other component of e(g)*.
This molecule achieves its most
stable structure by distorting
in response to the unequal
occupation of e(g)*.
And I will just show you what
that orbital looks like by
quitting out of there.
Now this graphic,
sadly, isn't as nice as the one
I could have shown you using my
laptop and VMD,
but it will have to serve the
purpose.
And this is just a snapshot of
the orbital.
It may not be possible to
increase the size of this.
Here we go.
I think it should be clear,
from your inspection of this
diagram, that we actually
superposed a couple of different
representations of the system on
top of one another.
First of all,
this program has drawn balls
and sticks to connect the atoms.
You have a red ball here,
a red ball.
Each place there is a red ball,
that is an oxygen.
And at the center,
we have our chromium plus two
ion.
So these are our water
molecules.
And what you should be able to
see here is that this orbital,
on this water molecule up here
along positive z,
has an appearance that would
suggest that that is the highest
occupied molecular orbital of
the water molecule,
interacting with the big lobe
of d z squared in
this antibonding fashion where
we go from blue phase to red
phase as we go along the sigma
axis between the oxygen and the
metal center.
And then, in a better
representation,
you would be able to see that
there are small contributions
from the four water molecules
that are interacting here with
the torus of the d z squared
orbital.
And then what you have down on
negative z is equal to what you
have on positive z.
Namely, you have an oxygen lone
pair here that is being repelled
by the electron occupying d z
squared,
which is one of our e(g)
components.
The idea is that systems like
this exchange water so very
rapidly, 15 orders of magnitude
more rapidly than a simple d
three system,
because two of the water
molecules are repelled away from
the metal center quite a bit.
And it makes this structure
close to the transition state
for just losing a water molecule
from the coordination sphere and
dissociating it from the metal
center.
And that is what we are going
to talk about next.
Now, we are going to talk about
a reaction like that in terms of
a potential energy surface
diagram.
We have seen how d orbital
occupation affects color and
magnetism and bonding between
metals and ligands.
And now we are seeing how
actually we can interpret
chemical reaction rates on the
basis of these electronic
structure considerations.
We like to draw energy level
diagrams that have orbitals on
them or states on them,
but sometimes what we like to
do is to try to describe the
total energy of the system,
fold all these different
coordinates into one and look at
the total energy of the system
as a function of where we are
along a chemical reaction
coordinate.
That means as we progress
through a sequence of elementary
steps corresponding to a
chemical reaction.
A complete description of any
reaction implies a knowledge of
the potential energy surface for
the reaction.
We have our reaction
coordinate, and we desire some
kind of a plot that could
represent this reaction
coordinate.
And what that plot looks like
depends on the particular
reaction mechanism of the
reaction that you are
scrutinizing.
If you have a reaction and you
want to know how it works,
the first thing you do is make
a hypothesis.
And from your hypothesis,
you can build predictions about
the reaction coordinate,
and then you can test those
experimentally.
And either your hypothesis will
turn out to be consistent with
the predictions or not.
And, if not,
you reject the hypothesis and
start again.
It has been said,
concerning reaction mechanisms,
that the closest you can get to
the truth is your own best
guess.
But the way that people test
reaction mechanisms is through
studying reaction rates under
various conditions and comparing
the results to those predicted
by your hypothesis.
And so here is a hypothesis for
a dissociative mechanism for the
type of ligand substitution
reaction that we are talking
about.
A dissociative mechanism means
that the mechanism proceeds by
dissociation of one of the
ligands from the metal center as
the first important step of the
reaction.
We have down here some ML five
X compound.
And let's say we have it in a
solvent Y, where the solvent can
also act as a ligand.
And we are interested in what
rate profile will we have if,
at the end of the reaction,
down here in this well,
this is meant to represent a
potential energy well where now
we have X replaced by Y,
--
-- as illustrated there.
That is the overall result of
the reaction.
But how does it take place?
Are there any intermediates in
the reaction?
And so, in a dissociative
mechanism, what happens is that
there is an intermediate.
And it occurs here in this
intermediate well.
One thing that you are going to
be interested in distinguishing
between, on potential energy
diagrams, will be potential
energy minima.
Because these potential energy
minima that I have just colored
in, those correspond to starting
materials, products,
or intermediates.
And then, alternatively,
you can have potential energy
maxima on the potential energy
surface.
This is a two-dimensional
diagram.
And what it really represents
is a two-dimensional slice
through a three-dimensional
surface that has hills and
valleys on it.
And these hills on the
potential energy surface
represent energy barriers to a
chemical reaction.
What we are going to have at
these points of high energy will
be things that we call
transition states.
And you start out down here at
the starting materials,
the reaction will proceed to
the right, we are assuming in
this case, and you go up hill in
energy first.
You have to surmount this
energy barrier associated with
this first transition state,
or TS1.
And when you system has gone
over that first barrier,
if it is a dissociative
mechanism, that produces an
intermediate ML five.
Because X has dissociated from
the metal center and Y,
of course, being the solvent,
is still there.
And then, once we get down into
this well, this potential energy
minimum, this valley associated
with the intermediate ML five,
it is a five coordinate
intermediate,
so it should have a structure
of the trigonal bipyramid or the
structure of a square pyramid.
And, over there,
I was talking about the
distortion of that molecule
based on its occupation of e(g)*
having repelled two of the water
molecules farther away from the
metal than the other four.
And what that does is it begins
to lower the energy barrier here
to get over to TS1.
It makes it easier for one
ligand to fall off the metal
center because it is being
repelled by that d z squared
electron.
And what we will see is that we
can associate rate constants
with each of these barriers.
This is the second instance
today that I have used the term
rate constant.
And we are going to want to
distinguish the term "rate
constant" from the term
"reaction rate."
And one of our goals today is
to understand the difference
between a reaction rate and a
rate constant.
Going up this first hill,
over TS1 and down into the
intermediate state,
where you have a five
coordinate species and X has
become freely dissociated from
the metal center,
that is k1.
And then, when you are down in
the valley, there are two ways
out of the valley.
You can either go back in the
direction of TS1.
We call that back reaction k
minus one.
We associate the rate constant
k minus one with the back
reaction that would take us back
over the same transition state
and back to the starting
materials.
That would be a nonproductive
step because it is going in the
wrong direction.
And then, over here,
ML five has this
branching option.
When you are at the stage of
the intermediate,
you can go either back to
starting materials or you can go
onto products.
And this rate constant we will
call k two for the
reaction in which the molecule Y
that is doing the substituting
would add to ML five.
That is associated with some
barrier.
And it produces the six
coordinate ML five Y and X
dissociated.
And then, finally,
in this last step we would call
the rate constant associated
with going back into the
intermediate from the products,
we would call that k minus two
for that rate
constant.
This is how you begin to write
out the math associated with a
hypothetical reaction mechanism.
And so, for those of you who
are gearing up to take 18.03
next semester,
Differential Equations,
you are going to find that this
is one area in chemistry where
differential equations become
extremely valuable.
Because you are going to
generate differential equations
that describe the kinetics of a
chemical reaction system.
And those equations will differ
depending on the hypothetical
mechanism.
And you are going to want to
figure out which hypothetical
mechanism actually fits your
data.
Here is one limiting case,
but let me first just --
I am going to leave that,
given the amount of time here.
We are going to go ahead and
talk about a limiting case.
When I use square brackets
here, I am going to be talking
about concentration,
just like we did when we were
talking about acids and bases
and so forth.
Square brackets denote
concentrations.
If k2 times Y,
and I will stick with the green
color for Y, is much greater
than k minus one times the
concentration of X,
hat corresponds to
a limiting case.
We are also going to make
another assumption,
here.
We are going to say assuming
complete reaction.
What does that mean?
That means that k minus two
times the concentration of ML
five Y times the concentration
of X at the end
corresponds to essentially
a negligible back reaction such
that when we get to products we
stop, this is a very deep well,
and we don't go back anymore
once we get over to the
products.
Under those conditions,
we have made two
simplifications.
Then, the reaction rate.
And, when we talk about
reaction rate,
we usually define it in terms
of the disappearance of the
starting materials or
alternatively the appearance of
the products,
the rate of appearance of the
products in a system like this.
And, under the conditions of
those assumptions,
the reaction rate is going to
depend on k1 times the
concentration of the starting
material.
Times the concentration of our
entering group Y.
And that says that every time
we get over the first barrier,
we rapidly get over the second
barrier without going back.
That is the assumption here
that k two times the
concentration of Y is much
greater than k minus one times
the concentration of X.
This is
often true when the
concentration of Y is very
great.
i.e., Y is the solvent.
In the case of water,
you have essentially 12 molar
Y.
Y is your solvent.
And, because of that,
under these circumstances,
the concentration of Y,
which is very large,
does not change effectively
during the reaction.
It is a constant that can be
folded into together with the
constant k1.
So we can describe this as k
observed.
K observed is equal to k1 times
Y times ML five X. And
these are what we call
pseudo-first order conditions.
That is a particularly simple
rate law.
And a lot of times,
experimentalists will engender
pseudo-first order conditions by
purposely using an entering
group concentration that is very
large.
And, when you do that,
you will find that,
for example,
the change in concentration
with time of ML five X
is, upon integration,
when you integrate differential
equations such as this,
you can obtain expressions for
the concentrations of these
species of interest as a
function of time.
So we can obtain ML five X of t
divided by ML five X at t equals
zero is equal to e to the minus
k observed, that contains that
large invariant concentration of
y folded into it times t.
Hence, this single exponential
decay of the starting materials
predicted by this mechanism
under these conditions for the
change in concentration with
time of your starting material.
Finally, what you do seek is to
follow, as a function of time,
the concentration of the
species involved such that,
for example,
you may be following,
here, the decay of your
starting species ML five X.
As a function of time,
you seek an expression for
that.
There are different methods to
carry out the integration
required for more complicated
rate laws than did appear there
for the pseudo first-order
mechanism.
But, simultaneously,
as ML five X decays,
the concentration of ML five Y
would be increasing.
And under the simple case shown
here, where the intermediate
does not build up to any
substantial concentration,
this is no buildup of
intermediate,
meaning whenever the
intermediate is formed it either
goes back to starting materials
or goes on to products.
In other words,
the intermediate never attains
significant concentrations
relative to starting materials
and final products.
This is the basis for the
steady state approximation that
is explained in your notes.
And I will go through that also
at the beginning of the hour on
Friday.
Have a nice day.